vont-ils trouver les trésors des rois de
france passé par saint germain en laye
tel est l'énigme de la toute nouvelle
salle la mine
ouverte il ya moins d'un mois et la
quatrième de l'entreprise en deux ans un
succès qui s'explique par la singularité
des énigmes selon nous c'est de faire
des sales original concret nous mêmes de
a à z des scénarios on les choisit nous
mêmes aussi nous qui créons les énigmes
les décors c'est nous qui les concevons
et c'est aussi de faire de la qualité
donc on essaie de faire des salles bien
réfléchi avec des mécanismes innovantes
par mois ce sont mille visiteurs qui
viennent essayer les différentes salles
proposé ce jour là ils étaient trois
amis à vouloir se mettre dans la peau de
chercheurs d'or pendant une heure c'est
l'idée du
un scénario pendant une heure c'est un
peu comme je le jeu vidéo mais dans la
vraie vie autrement
quérard on est à sa 5ème énigme elle a
commencé à comprendre les rouages des
escape game sans pour autant gagner à
tous les coups
peut-être qu'on est plus concentré sur
les petits détails et cetera on sait par
qui est un peu moins mais après ça
dépend aussi de la difficulté et puis
des gens avec lille on le fait si la
communication est bonne et puis le mode
aussi dans lequel on est le jour même
ainsi on a envie de réussir ou pas du
tout et aujourd'hui les trois amis
avaient l'envi de trouver le trésor
le fait de coopérer entre les joueurs
pour résoudre un mystère est aussi un
avantage des escales pick n ya pas
vraiment de notion de concurrence entre
les joueurs qui viennent ensemble et
c'est en fait les gens viennent
rechercher l'immersion ensemble quoi
c'est comme si vous étiez avec vos amis
ou votre famille dans des décors de
disneyland ou de cinéma
rien qu'à vous rendre pour vous pour
résoudre des énigmes et où est ben c'est
ça qui plaît beaucoup dans quelques mois
de nouvelles salles vont être ouvertes à
saint-germain-en-laye dont shoop shoop
est un scénario décalé et humoristique
les joueurs devront retrouver choupette
un yorkshire d'une riche saint
germanoise sachant que les ravisseurs
sont peut être des chats vaudou qui
serait à l'origine de plusieurs
disparitions de chiens